Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, yesterday I
asked you all to submit Game of Thrones questions
so today we’ll see what everyone has to
say about what’s really going with the gods.
I always like the what would you be if you
were in the story questions.
I’ll announce who won the book after we
get through everything, if you are just finding
me the book giveaway happens every week when
I post my bonus videos. The next one starts
next week so be sure to subscribe to get it.
General spoilers for everything through season
4 I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Question 1 - Shadow Wolf asks do dragons have
gods?
The dragons are more like animals. Like really
intuitive flying lizards. I think they just
operate on primal instinct. But they are connected
to the balance of nature in a way that hasn’t
been fully explained.
It’s more likely that people would have
worshipped them prior to the valyrians learning
how to domesticate them. In a sense they’re
a lot like horses to the Dothraki. They are
a part of the culture and highly respected.
You could argue that they serve nature or
the old gods, but worshiping a god and serving
one are two different things.
I think Dragons are connected to fire magic,
R’hollor is presented as the Lord of Light.
So you could link them to him too.
Then there are the Daenerys Azor Ahai theories.
Which I think I’ve talked about in my other
theory videos. So if you had to pick I would
say they exist on the side Red God or The
Old Gods, but I don’t think it’s going
to be that simple.
Just to explain how they’re connected to
fire magic it’s really the seasons. Back
when dragons started to proliferate more the
world started to get hotter. So the summer
season became much longer, then after the
last dragon died the world started to cool
again. That was in the years preceding the
show. Thus Winter is Coming.
Thus, Dragons have a certain connection to
the balance of seasons.
Question 2 - Rainbow fish bubbles asks Do
out think that the children might someday
serve the great other? Or will the children
make the white walkers bow down to them and
their gods?
The Children were involved in stopping the
forces of the great other at the end of the
Long Night. It’s implied that a peace treaty
was brokered and they were involved in sealing
that pact.
I think they’re more of a neutral force
serving nature. They want balance, so if one
side got too powerful, they would probably
work with the other side to create balance.
There is a theory that the three eyed raven
will be a champion of the great other, but
that doesn’t mean that he’s evil. And
if Priests of the Red God can disagree then
so can greenseers. The three eyed raven was
the last greenseer until bran came to learn
from him.
So even if the children work on the opposing
side of the red god, it doesn’t mean they
are surrendering or bowing down. It would
probably only be in service of the natural
order of things.
For instance, if Dragons can make the world
hotter, and they started to overpopulate,
the world would turn into one giant desert.
So the forces of cold or night or however
you want to think about it would have to suppress
them until the world returned to a more balanced
Question 3 - Ablix asks Who did the Valyrians
worship?
They worshiped a wide variety of dieties,
there wasn’t a main religion. The Valyrian
freehold was created after the Valyrians tamed
dragons and used them to conquer the eastern
continent.
So just like Greeks or the Romans, you ended
up with a wide variety of citizens from conquered
nations all with their own gods.
Beyond that we don’t know if the Valyrians
worshipped any specific deity before they
tamed dragons. Because they lived in this
area near slaver’s bay and the summer sea
you can point to precursors of a lot of the
different gods people worship in Mereen.
I’m not an expert on the evolution of religions
in the world. Most early religion was just
tied to burial rites. Like the way the religion
of the Old gods doesn’t have a lot of complex
customs.
George RR Martin has teased that he’ll write
flashbacks to old valyria before the doom.
So be sure to read winds of winter and dream
of spring when they come out.
So far, the only people in the series that
have claimed to actually travel there is Euron
Greyjoy and it seems like the show isn’t
going to do his character.
Tywin Lannister’s youngest brother Gerion
Lannister traveled to Valyria to try and recover
Brighroar, the lost Valyrian blade of House
Lannister. But he never returned. He’s kind
of interesting in that he wasn’t a huge
fan of Tywin and tried to help Tyrion learn
history as a child.
I don’t think the show is going to do that
character, but Tyrion might run into him again
in the books in the east.
Question 4 - Edward Faull asks What do you
think is going to happen at the end of the
series
As spoilery as this could be I talked about
a white walker prophecy theory in a video.
I’ll add a link for those that want to watch
it.
It’s all about brokering a truce in the
name of balance. But a
lot of the alliegences on the show right now
will shift and the people you think are heroes
might end up being villians.
You can just watch that video for a much more
detailed breakdown.
Question 5 - Johanna Adams asks can weirwood
trees be grown or transplanted?
Probably not transplanted but they can certainly
be grown. So you could plant and grow new
ones. But I don’t think they’re like the
ents in Lord of the Rings. The trees are connected
to a certain type of nature magic, but they’re
not going to just pick up and start running
around.
We’ll learn more about them in winds of
winter and season 5.
Question 6 - Brian Navarro asks does the Great
Other have sleeper cells around the world
and are there other people that worship
the great other?
I think it will look more like what you saw
during Aegon’s Conquest. He allowed people
to surrender or join his army.
You start with your forces in the Lands of
Always Winter, then as they push south they
slowly kill people and turn them into wights
making their army stronger. Aegon allowed
people to surrender and join his army.
Since we saw that white walker march past
Samwell in season 2 it’s possible that they
could leave people alone if they’re not
perceived to be a threat.
So the further south the White Walkers push,
the larger their army grows.
At a certain point I think we’ll see people
try to serve the true balance of nature and
if the forces of the red god are doing something
to thwart that people could take action against
them. But that doesn’t mean that they’d
be serving the White Walkers or the Great
Other.
A really simple way to think of it would be
the enemy of my enemy is my friend. You could
start to see a lot of that.
Question 7 - Tomo asks who’s storyline are
they going to cut out in season 5?
They’re not so much cutting storyline’s
out as they’re cutting characters out and
giving those stories to other characters.
For example, we haven’t heard about any
Greyjoy Uncle castings, those people do a
few notable things in book 4. It’s possible
that they could give those parts of the story
to Theon’s sister, Yara. Her name in the
books is different than on the show. But you
get the idea.
The did the same thing with Gendry giving
him Edric Storm’s story and giving Hot Pie
Gendry’s story.
The big parts of the story stay close to the
books, the biggest changes are always the
characters themselves.
Question 8 - VOD asks if you had to choose
a religion which one would you pick?
I do like me some resurrection but I’d probably
pick the Old Gods, just so I wouldn’t have
to sit through long boring rituals or church
sermons like in the faith of the seven.
A lot of times it feels like in the books,
people’s religions have a lot to do with
their personalities, like arya worships death
because she’s so hardcore. But before she
worshipped the old gods like her family.
I feel like my personality changes year to
year just as much as some of the characters,
so the god I worship would probably change
over time too. But right now, I’ll keep
it simple and say a prayer at a heart tree
every once and a while.
Question 9 - Virus asks, where is the Blackfish?
Where has he been since the Red Wedding?
This is a rare case when the show and the
books do the same thing. He escaped the Red
Wedding Massacre because he was outside the
castle when shit went down. He ran back to
Riverrun and has been holed up there since
then.
If you remember, Riverrun sits on a small
piece of land in a body of water. So when
he pulls the drawbridge up. The castle can
only be reached by boat. So they can’t just
march an army up to it’s gates.
The show is changing what happens after that.
Based on the characters that they killed of
during the red wedding it seems like they’re
just going to cut the Blackfish out of the
story unless he shows up in some other way.
He has a pretty notable story in Book 4. But
again, they’re not doing that on the show.
In both cases, he ends up alive and on the
run. So he can always come back into the story
in a future season.
and Question 10 last one - Nicole Mott asks
do people get rez sickness when they get brought
back to life? Reduced stats suck.
I laughed a little when I saw this because
I used to be addicted to Warcraft. And yes,
there is a certain level of Rez Sickness and
reduced stats each time you get brought back.
Beric Dondarrion on the show says that each
time R’hollor brings him back from the dead
it feels like a little piece of him gets left
behind. So presumably there is a limit to
the number of times someone can be brought
back.
Or at a certain point you just become a mindless
soulless zombie.
I know the show cut Lady Stoneheart out, but
so far she’s the furthest gone that we’ve
seen someone come back from. But I think she
was a special case due to the circumstances
of her death and the will of her mind.
But hopefully that answers some of you guys
questions. Thanks for sending them in. My
next bonus video will be about the civil war
with the faith militant. That was a long long
time before events on the show but it’s
really interesting. I’ll post it Sunday.
And congratulations to this week’s giveaway
winner. Marcus Gaskins. You win your choice
of any of Martin’s books you want. Kindle
or paperback. I’ll message you on your channel
for details.
Remember all you guys have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment when
I post bonus videos.
Lots of stuff happening this week so I’ll
be posting updates on twitter and facebook.
links to that at the bottom of the description
and in the meantime learn about my white walker
prophecy by clicking here and click here to
learn all about the faceless men.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!